and what people don't get as well is I
have a couple of friends too it takes
them like five hours to press out their
hair their curls like my friend Ava I'm
like are you still in the bathroom like
how are you still in the bathroom doing
she's late girl takes me forever to get
it to and I'm like cool girl that was me
at 1:00 a.m.
brushing my hair my mama knows I was
pressing my hair every day not only at
the time but the resources the wigs that
women have to buy just so that they have
the straight hair the weaves like we're
talking about a lot of money that put
ideally we do two at a disadvantage but
do you always wear your hair naturally
now I do you know it's very rare when I
straighten my hair and I think going
through that experience and I told you
about I think it's just made me so much
more proud of Who I am and it also
reminded me of the position that I'm in
that hopefully I can inspire young girls
young girls of color white girls Brown
girls every kind of girl out there who
is feeling ashamed of of some part of
who they are and and what they were
given by God I don't want them to feel
that and so I hope that whenever I rock
my curls on the air there's one more
little girl out there who's encouraged
to do this I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this